scientists have been researching a rocky
planet in the trappist-1 system and
they've discovered that it will it sucks
the Hope was this exoplanet would be
just the right distance from its star
and would have an atmosphere capable of
sustaining life but it turns out this
planet is too close to its star and it
receives four times as much irradiation
from it than Earth does from the Sun
making the daytime temperature of this
world a whopping 230 Celsius 450
Fahrenheit it would feel like living in
your oven now trappist-1b is just one of
several planets surrounding its red
dwarf star it's just outside the
habitable zone so it was no surprise
when scientists found out it had little
to no atmosphere but planets e f and g
are in the habitable zone and could
potentially have liquid water
trappist-1f could even look something
like this